hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll i forget whether i've told this
story before but back in the early days
of the world wide web so not the
internet the internet goes back further
but the idea of web browsers right uh
their first text text-based web browsers
there's one called links lynx which is a
pun
because you clicked on a link uh
eventually there were image-based web
browsers mosaic from ncsa was
everybody's favorite thing and then
ultimately netscape netscape was the
real time when not only could you see
images in your web browser but it was
relatively fast you didn't have to wait
for 10 minutes for a page to download
and also netscape was important because
it was commercialized they had an
initial public offering and people were
very very excited and as an early
adopter of the web i was there i used
netscape all the time i was very excited
i had no money to invest so i was not
part of the big bubble in the netscape
stock prices but i was asked by my
friends who had no idea what the web was
like what's the big deal why is this
going to be so important and i honestly
couldn't do a very good job of
explaining why it was going to be
important i had an intuition had a
feeling this was going to be a big deal
i would have invested in netscape had
there been money
but when people asked like how are they
going to make money off of that i really
couldn't answer i did not have a good
idea like i could point to actual web
pages that existed but they were largely
along the lines of you know a video
camera pointing at a coffee maker so you
could see whether there was coffee in
the coffee maker or not and no one was
impressed by that you could order pizza
but people knew how to order pizza by
using the phone so again what was the
point anyway the point of the story is
the future is hard to predict
even if you know something specific is
going to happen the implications of
whatever it is is going to happen can be
very very hard to anticipate there's so
many moving parts in society and
technology in the world that predicting
the future can be very very tricky so
today's guest jane mcgonigle
started out and became well known as a
game designer and also author and has
moved into being a futurist
systematically predicting imagining what
the future is going to be like and you
might wonder what is the connection
between these two things but if you're a
game designer i don't mean games like
solitaire or candy crush i mean these
massive multiplayer games where you have
an avatar and there's a world you've
built a world and there are rules they
might not be the same rules as our world
but you can kind of see when you put it
that way what the connection is between
game design and futurism because when
you're predicting the future you're
trying to simulate an extraordinarily
complex system and oftentimes you can't
actually make the prediction yourself
you have to let people follow the rules
of the game and see what's going to
happen it is very often the case that
things happen in these massive games
where the game designers themselves did
not predict it that's exactly the kind
of thing you have in the future you
might imagine doing a simulation of the
future giving a bunch of people
different parameters different changes
that society's undergone different
technological or scientific advances and
asking them how they would adapt
i'm not going to give away
any of the secrets here but jane's
message is that we can become better at
thinking about the future and imagining
what's going to happen we can train our
brains to do it games are one way of
doing it but there's other ways of
thinking about the future in more
productive ways anyone who's lived
through the past couple years can no
doubt understand how important it is to
get a better handle on what the future
is going to be like so let's go
[Music]
jane mcgonagall welcome to the mindscape
podcast
thank you i'm very excited to be here
this is very exciting because i just
told you before we started recording
i've been wanting to have you on the
podcast for a long time to talk about
games and gaming but now you've come out
with a completely different book
imaginable about futurism thinking about
the future but i still want to start
with the games if that's okay because i
do think it actually
it makes sense to me how you started out
as a game designer and then became more
of a futurist so maybe uh i'm sure that
there are some heavy gamers in the
audience and some not so much so why
don't you give your sales pitch or
explanation for how important gaming is
to the modern world
um sure well so you know my research
background is studying
the psychological impacts of playing
video games and
when i was doing my phd i became kind of
obsessed with
with the sense that
gamers were developing skills and
abilities
that might have
some
transferable benefit to
our real world problems and
i mean i came i came to this you know
obsession because
gamers were worth saying give us
something real right and all these
online communities and forums
they seemed hungry for non-virtual
challenges uh to solve
and so i kind of made it my business to
figure out
could we invent a new genre of games
that it still feels like play but it
really taps into that unique skill set
of
a flexible mindset and creative thinking
and collaboration and collective
intelligence and this kind of
unbelievable resilience that gamers have
where if they can't figure something out
right away they stay with it and you
know it just seemed like such a great
skill set to apply to things like
climate change and ending poverty and
imagining a better world and
that's
and that's how i kind of transitioned
into
becoming a game developer myself trying
to experiment with different genres of
games that might might connect gamers
abilities with with real world
challenges well and one thing you point
out right there is that there is a
tremendous amount of effort and
intellectual
uh exertion right now
being put into the world by gamers
and i don't know whether in your mind a
gamer is someone who is just playing
some
console or pc game where does it count
to play solitaire on your iphone also
oh well i mean
does it count
you know so i've spent like 20 years now
studying the psychology of games and
solitaire could count for something it
could count for your regulating your
thoughts and emotions you're using the
game to turn off you know depressive
rumination or to stop you know a panic
attack and it's you know
you're controlling your imagination to
not have anxious thoughts i mean yes so
i mean solitaire in your phone could
count for something solitary in your
phone especially if you've been playing
it for 20 or 30 or 40 years as many
people like they find a game they like
and that's the only game they play i
mean that does not
necessarily lend itself to
developing a collective intelligence
skill set because you're playing by
yourself um there's a certain
there's a certain
like superpower the ability to learn new
systems quickly that comes from playing
games that you've never played before
new interfaces new genres new challenges
so i mean i always say like if you want
the benefits and skill sets of gaming
you really do want to be
trying different games and particularly
ones that many other people are playing
because so
so much of what's interesting about
gaming comes from that that collective
collaborative culture yeah and maybe
this is just worth spelling out for
again probably there's some people who
just don't do this at all and maybe they
have an image of games as mostly you're
shooting other people or aliens or or
something like that but the the social
aspects and not just social in the sense
that you're collaborating and
cooperating but there's a different kind
of society that appears within the game
and this is something that is uh
a brave new world that you know many
people already dived into but many
people are completely shut out from
yeah and i mean like one of my favorite
examples from recent gaming history is
pokemon go
so pokemon go amazing augmented reality
game it just kind of dropped without a
lot of
preliminary instruction like here's what
to expect from this game here's how it
works here's how to play it just kind of
dropped and within 30 i think it was 30
days 30 to 60 days it was half a billion
downloads it was the fastest growing
product or service in human history
going back to like the invention of fire
or the wheel
never before we've seen more people try
something new faster and what was so fun
to watch was this
explosion of wikis and forums and
youtube videos and walkthroughs and
screen captures people trying to figure
out how does this game work what are we
supposed to do what are the tricks and
tips and what what's like the full
spectrum of possibility here and and the
players taught themselves they taught
each other it was like this scientific
investigation we could all develop
hypotheses am i supposed to do this if i
play it like this will it work and
everybody was learning together and
documenting this game together and i
mean i just i kind of just love that
niantic dropped the game without a lot
of explanation because it allowed this
incredible explosion of collaborative
collective investigation and for me
that's what's most interesting about any
video game culture whether it's
minecraft or fortnite you know people
are exploring
the full possibility space or pushing on
the limits of the code and and the the
problem space and there's so much just
creativity and sharing and teaching
in all of these games and uh and so i
you know that to me that's what's
exciting about it and it's very social
you know but it's but it's social in an
interesting way that really
really values
teaching and co-learning and and helping
even if the games are competitive even
if you're shooting virtual weapons at
each other you know it's still this
intensely collaborative collective
culture and i love that and we should we
should bring it to
all aspects of our lives
well there seems that a practical level
maybe to be a barrier to entry if you're
you know a person of a certain age who
did not grow up doing this kind of thing
and you know you look in the store and
there's these consoles and these you
know these people spend hours and hours
every day doing this and how can you
compete i mean do you think that
everyone should roughly speaking be
thinking about or participating in games
like this or do you think that it's a
you know for some people it's good and
for others take it or leave it
no i mean i i do think
essentially every human being should
participate in some gaming culture in
the same way that i would say every
human being should read and should
exercise i mean it does seem like
essential fuel for our creativity and
our our mental resilience and our the
range of positive emotions that we feel
now i will i i never tell anyone to go
out and buy a gaming console unless
they're like into it you can play
i just use your phone use your personal
computer
um
there's an infinite number of games and
i always say if you're if you're not
sure where to start i mean just post on
social media ask ask your friends and
family
what's it what's what do you think i
should be playing right now and are you
willing to teach me if i don't know how
to play it because you know one of the
biggest social benefits of playing these
games is you develop
something in common with other people in
your life you know i i mean i'll never
forget how important it was to me when
my daughters were born seven years ago
and i started spending a lot more time
with my mother-in-law who was helping us
care for twins which is you know a lot
of work
and um she started playing candy crush
saga which was like the only game i had
the energy to play when after her
daughters were born and she just emailed
me a few weeks ago saying that she had
gotten to level 3000 and was so glad she
hadn't given up she was going to stop at
like level 250. and it's just it's it's
it's this thing we still have in common
seven years later i'm not still playing
this game but i understand it we can
talk about what's challenging about it i
can log in and send her some gifts to
help her um you know if she's stuck on a
level
building this this common foundation it
allows us to keep the conversation going
people interact more and have
conversations about real world topics
more with people that they play these
games with even if we're just like doing
you know pokemon go raids together
virtually you know every few weeks we're
more likely to talk about other stuff it
just creates this rhythm of interaction
and this common foundation so yeah if
you don't know what to play ask people
you already have relationships with what
they're playing people you might like to
talk to more often have something more
in common with that common experience
and and then yeah make them teach you
it's great people love people who love
games love teaching other people how to
play so it lets them be that's true you
know in that position of mentoring of
coaching which is again it's a huge
positive social
benefit
well you make some provocative
statements about the emotional or
psychological impact of games i mean
there's both
who we are in the game and then how that
affects our personality outside you've
said that we're our best selves when
we're inside a game what what do you
mean by that and i should say
often we are our best selves
sometimes we get stuck and not all
gaming communities are equally positive
i mean there are certainly toxic gaming
communities and there are games that i
don't participate in because like people
do kind of get angry at each other too
often so i will say if we're talking
broadly speaking
um
the
that gaming does develop this
psychological self-efficacy right so
games are designed to be challenging and
hard and frustrate us and if we play a
game we have to be willing to be
frustrated we have to be willing to be
challenged to be bad at something to get
that feedback like nope not good not
right not working and so we develop this
ease and comfort with not being good at
something the first time we try it of
managing these negative emotions which
frustration and confusion and
uncertainty
and we put ourselves in a position to
get better at dealing with them by
staying engaged with the game and games
are designed you know very carefully and
purposefully so that alongside that
frustration there's hope there is you
know always something around the corner
that might make you a little bit
stronger in the game or give you a tip
or you can go online and you can learn
from other players you're not in it
alone even if it's a solo game you're
never in it alone so we learned to ask
for help from others or advice from
others we we learn to try again and
truly
it's just it's such a wonderful
way of being being comfortable
with needing to grow needing to improve
through our own effort and attention and
it does seem to be transferable to other
situations there have been laboratory
studies where
you can separate people into groups that
frequently game and ga and people who
don't or you can get people who don't
game and you can put them through a
six-week gaming boot camp and then see
have they changed their their response
to
um you know purposefully difficult
work you know perp intentionally
impossible puzzles to solve you know do
they do they try more strategies do they
stay engaged how fast do they give up
are they likely to turn to the other
person in the lab and ask them for help
you know we see that these behaviors
they they can translate to
our our real world interactions not just
in the virtual world and
what i have found in my work with with
gamers and and also
you know validated reflected in the
research literature is that actually
having conversations about this skill
set helps it translate so you know i
have kids when i see them not giving up
in a game i make sure to validate that
and reflect that back to them be like
that's amazing like i know you've been
trying to get off this level for a while
how many times have you tried 100 times
gosh i love how determined you are i
love i love that you're not someone who
doesn't give up when things are hard you
know when we when we talk to each other
and and and
reflect this skill set than people
whether they're kids or the grown-ups
everybody we're more likely to
see ourselves
as this is part of our identity i'm
someone who doesn't give up i'm someone
who can always come up with a new idea
or strategy i'm someone who knows where
to get help or not afraid to ask for
help um and we bring that with us so
you know yes that is that is the core
benefit and we should we should lean
into it and we should get it
and meanwhile you alluded this already
but these people are learning skills
whether it's concentration or puzzle
solving or whatever and so it is very
natural to ask because i guess to back
up a little bit
the the flip side of everything you're
saying is couldn't these people be doing
something more productive with all the
time that they're putting into the games
and i think that part of your answer is
why not both why not do it at the same
time
yeah i mean like just to kind of put the
amount of human effort being poured into
games still into context so think about
a game like candy crush saga which i
don't know the game flip been around for
almost a decade now i think the amount
of time that people are still spending
playing this game
is equivalent to the three biggest
organizations on earth so i think it's
like it's like walmart's mcdonald's and
the chinese army something i forget i've
heard exactly what the three
organizations are but
the amount of human labor spent
solving candy crush levels is equivalent
to the three largest organizations on
earth and how much time is still spent
every day um and so it is natural to ask
like could we siphon a little bit of
that off i mean
it's like
not all of our time has to be productive
there is i mean for you know my god i'm
not saying like we all play has to have
a serious purpose
but yeah maybe we maybe we spend one of
the 20 hours a week we spend gaming
playing games
that
help us build that bridge between what
we're good at in these virtual
environments and what the world really
needs which is more creativity and the
ability to anticipate
i you know for me personally my passion
is gamers anticipating future risk
future global threats how we could
prepare how we could respond how we
could help others whether it's pandemics
or mass climate migration or
unanticipated consequences of
geoengineering efforts that's that's
where i think you know come spend spend
one of these 21 hours a week you're
spending gaming on um one of these cool
future forecasting games well as a game
designer have you discovered that things
happen in the game that you the designer
did not anticipate just because it is
kind of handed over to a bunch of smart
people trying to solve puzzles in a
different way oh absolutely i mean that
right so game developers call that
emergence it's when you design a certain
set of challenges or rules or behaviors
and then players show up and they're
doing something totally different from
what you anticipated which is why you
know when it comes to forecasting the
future i don't think you can do better
than to invite a bunch of people who who
have that facility of surprising you and
surprising each other because you know
when it when we
one of the one of the issues we have in
really being prepared for the future is
we have this kind of normalcy bias where
we assume things will continue the way
they are we expect the future to be more
or less like the present and we kind of
need some people to surprise us and
shake us up and say like whoa you think
that's what's gonna happen well if i
were in the future you know here's what
i do and when i when i design these um
future forecasting games i always try to
assign a certain subset of the community
to be you know what i would call the
griefers which are people who
only job in this simulation is look at
what other people are trying to do the
solutions they propose the positive
actions they say they would take and
uh and try to mess it up like what would
you do to break it to
block it to
twist twisted into something that
creates social division um
you know
in because we know like if one thing
there's a subset of the gaming community
that's quite good at you know
antagonizing
other people's best efforts so we can
even we can even put that to good you
know by by um allowing them to channel
that energy into complicating you know
the other positive strategies that
people suggest so that again we're we're
more prepared for in the real world when
things you know do tend to become more
complicated or there may be opposition
that we didn't anticipate
so what's interesting i think i think i
get this but let me
say it out loud so you can tell me
whether i'm just projecting on to what's
going on i can certainly imagine trying
to understand more about the future
through simulation right i mean war
games or something like that try to do
that you just put a computer to work you
know what will happen no no
but no don't put a computer to work put
people to work but go ahead yeah no i
think i think this is exactly the sort
of new thing that you're saying is that
uh there's more room to be surprised if
rather than just putting the computer to
work yeah yeah develop a framework and
let human beings with all their quirks
and idiosyncrasies run free and then see
what happens yeah i mean here's the
problem with computer simulations like
let's say we're trying to simulate a
pandemic
so we're going to input some
algorithms into this computer that says
like okay if if the virus is this
contagious
and this many people
continue to socialize or go to work um
this is how many cases like you're
you're basically inputting what you
think are reasonable parameters and then
it crunches numbers and it says great
this many people will get sick this many
people will die as many people with
disability whatever um okay that's fine
assuming your assumptions are correct
but
what we saw with this pandemic is people
do all kinds of things that experts did
not anticipate oh you're you have a
positive test you should stay home no
i'm going to church you know like i mean
well you can't you're sick don't go to
work i have to work i how am i going to
make money you haven't sent me a check
to stay home so i'm going to work you
know wear a mask it's totally reasonable
it's like no
mask resistance like
if you just said a computer simulation
to simulate
pandemics you're going to miss this
incredible complexity of of human
emotion and needs and what drives us and
motivates us and um you know so when i
do a simulation of a pandemic what i do
is i get um you know the first time we
did this we had 8 000 people the next
time 20 000 people we say okay we're
gonna spend some time together six weeks
ten weeks we're gonna tell you about
this fictional scenario this pandemic
we're living through other complicating
factors like supply chain disruptions or
misinformation theories you know
spreading on social media will give you
some extra you know as as the game
unfolds more information about what's
going on all you have to do is tell us
what you would do what you would feel
what you would need how you would try to
help others and if we can
ask you questions
just give us your your your you know
your intuitive response based on what
you know about yourself
what are you likely to do so you've been
told to isolate for two weeks under what
circumstances do you violate this
disorder like disobey these instructions
the number one thing people said back in
2008 when we first started simulating
pandemics was for religious worship that
it was like so fundamental to their
their values their sense of purpose and
meaning that they're going to go to
church even if it's dangerous or even if
they're not supposed to and of course
that turned out to be the number one
super spreading risk all over the world
italy korea the u.s this is where all
the initial outbreaks were happening and
people were disobeying and it's where a
lot of the early
tension in the united states came from
the biggest resistance to
shutdowns were from religious
communities who saw it as a first
amendment issue and so it's like a lot
of the social divisiveness was coming
from you know experts failure to
anticipate how important this would be
and how divisive it would be um and uh
you know we asked people to practice
wearing masks right so hey six week game
try taking a real mask out we gave
people mass we said uh you know where to
work where to party wear it on public
transportation like what do you think
could you do this in a real pandemic
what would be
what would be weird about it you know
how comfortable is it and of course we
saw you know people
it wasn't so it wasn't just like people
wanted to or didn't want to we saw that
there was like a physical endurance
aspect to learning to be comfortable
wearing a mask that was not easy for
people who'd never done it before to
pick up we saw that people really were
frustrated by not being able to see each
other's faces and that the sort of
social disconnection of it um so you
know we anticipated that it would even
though it seems rational and it seems
easy to just adopt this behavior
that it was going to be
much more difficult in communities that
didn't have a practice or culture of it
right if you hadn't grown up
used to this
um so you know for me this is my passion
it's not it's not we don't want to leave
it to a few computer algorithms because
who knows if our algorithms are right
people are the algorithms in these
social simulations and we let them
surprise us
we look for patterns in what they're
saying or predicting and you know
it's based on this idea like people can
be experts on their own future and we if
we have this kind of bottom-up
intelligence
we'll be you know we'll be more prepared
for
surprising social consequences that
really aren't so surprising right like
one of the things i'll never forget
pretty much in every scenario we've run
the moms show up and they say well who's
going to take care of the kids in the
scenario it could be a pandemic in
schools closing it could be an oil
crisis so the buses stop running so no
one goes to school moms are always
showing up being like
what's going to happen am i going to
have to stop working to take care of the
kids and you know again we saw this mass
exodus of women from the workplace to do
caretaking when schools shut down i mean
when you run these scenarios you do get
a sense for the types of social
consequences that should be more front
of mind
should be you know even we had we had
somebody from um
who was living in upstate new york who
was
experienced with long-term the long form
of lyme disease and how
doctors dismissed this for i don't know
decades people they're saying it's all
in your mind this is psychological
you're depressed you're stressed um
you're anxious
and and predicting well they're probably
going to be long forms of this imaginary
pandemic and like some
and and of course you know they were
right
but the stuff tends to get dismissed by
experts at the outsets of real crises so
yeah that was a lot but you could say
i'm very passionate about letting
ordinary people into this process and
the power of collective imagination well
i'm actually as we're having this
conversation sitting in my guest office
at the santa fe institute uh where they
love complexity and emergent collective
computation and emergence is our
favorite word here the mindscape podcast
so this is all just you know candy to us
um but but in fact let's
let me ask more about the nitty-gritty
of this kind of simulation that you do
uh
i presume you're using computers here is
it is it what asking a whole bunch of
people to donate an hour a day or is it
in a virtual world or they just
answering questionnaires great okay so
we set up social networks
for these games so the actual game
interface looks depending on the game
and we've tried different versions of it
it might look like you're on twitter or
it might look like you're on facebook or
look like you're on discord and
um the core mechanic
is just participating okay in normal
social media activity there might be
polls to take surveys to take so we can
get like
get data in a way that is easy to
analyze like statistically
but the main thing that you're doing is
you are
posting little updates little text
updates or
photos or videos um of what you imagine
yourself doing in this future and it's
it's very social people start having
conversations if you're imagining um
what moms are doing and you might find
the other moms and you imagine together
and depending on
how long the format is
you might spend just
two whole days to basically do nothing
but being immersed in this so a lot of
the ones that we've run it's like a
48-hour thought experiment everybody's
online you might have you know a
thousand two thousand three thousand
people just basically
the sun sunrise the sunset we're in it
we're imagining it and then it's done
for the longer form ones you know i said
six weeks eight weeks ten weeks maybe
you drop in once a day
for
you know 15 minutes so you come once a
week for a few hours to really deeply
immerse yourself but the end result is
usually thousands of player generated
stories
that we can then analyze for you know
key themes we can do sentiment analysis
we can
follow up with essentially like deep
ethnographic interviews if we saw people
doing weird stuff that we want to
understand better my phd was in
performance studies which is a field
that has an ethnographic like a deep
tradition of ethnographic research where
you
where you're
you're studying human behavior by just
getting in there long conversations
looking for the rich
details of um
of what people want and feel and need
and so
you know so it's a combination of polls
surveys sentiment analysis
looking for key
themes trying to cluster the stories um
and uh and then following up with deep
ethnographic research
and uh
it's
it's uh
i i wrote this book you know imaginable
because we've been practicing it at the
institute for the future now for
a little over i say about 15 years now
and uh but it's kind of like a rare art
form it's like a rare skill set and i'm
hoping that other people will read the
book
learn how to design these social
simulations so there's
you know step by step i break down the
creative process the tools how you might
want to build it how you might want to
analyze it
and i'm hoping that you know in the
future we have
in the same way that like when video cat
home video cameras became available and
suddenly everybody could be a filmmaker
right and yeah and then blogs existed so
now everybody can be a journalist right
so i'm hoping we can all be simulation
designers in the future kind of
democratize this skill set and instead
of just playing with the scenarios that
i come up with or my fellow researchers
at the institute for the future come up
with
you know every organization can be
running their own scenarios and and
every foundation and social movement
but something we can all
we can all do together and in the real
example in the real world of a pandemic
or some future shock event
there's both what the individuals are
doing and then there's the external
forces that are pushing them right the
government
gives the money or doesn't give them
money shuts down air travel so how much
structure do you as the simulation
runner have to impose on what's
happening over time uh in this in this
kind of uh
is it simulation is that the right thing
to call it i call them social
simulations sometimes we call them
future forecasting games um
or immersive scenarios
this is like one of the cool things
about working on the bleeding edge of a
new genre
nobody calls it the same thing yet but
so i'm trying social simulation now um
for for me that's the that best sort of
summarizes what we're doing
um rather than a computer simulation
it's a social simulation playing out on
these these social networks from the
future right um
so we will usually plot out a series of
updates to the scenario
that um allow players to examine
different dimensions and these sort of
external forces so it's exactly right we
might say okay here's in super struck
which was the the first one in 2008
where we were looking at
the respiratory distress syndrome that
we imagine um we did we we would say
okay the government has decided not to
provide
economic support um for individuals who
um
are uh asked to isolate or who have
gotten sick and you know so
you know then we saw the players reacted
to that by creating essentially like an
activist movement to demand for
um
for this disability to be recognized and
care people to be paid to be caretakers
for their loved ones who have we know
and you know
some of that actually did
happen in during our real covenanting
experience and um
i think uh
i think it was
i think if we have more people playing
these games it will be that in itself
will be an important
skill that we develop like what do we
ask for during a crisis like let's
practice
demanding what we would need or calling
for change or or really understanding
what kind of help
mutual aid needs to emerge um it's you
know and not just sort of wait until the
real crisis hits and everyone's like ah
what what do we do
yeah but so we do provide these
narrative updates and you know in the
case of let's say evoke was the big one
i did with the world bank in 2010 we had
a weekly update
and uh in super shocked i think we were
we were dropping it like twice a week um
in world without oil which was one of
the first big future forecasting games
that had about 1200 players there were
daily updates for 30 days um so
you're uh you can like you can sort of
ex experiment with different uh
yeah and the fast ones the 48 hour ones
we do it every hour and you okay you
know theme or update so i don't know
we're still i'm still i'm still trying
to figure out what is the best timeline
um what i've sort of come to is it's
ideal if people can spend at least 10
days in a scenario because it allows it
to percolate and like really simmer in
your mind and you can get past your
obvious ideas into more complex and
nuanced and surprising ones and it also
gives you time to see what other people
are saying and imagining so that it's
more of a
collective activity
so that's so i'm right now i'm trying
the 10-day and and you spend you know an
hour a day in this future for ten days
which i think is a
people can commit to ten days six to six
to eight to ten weeks is a harder
commitment yeah that's a lot of life
it's hard to predict the future that far
in advance
and
there's always the question whenever you
have human beings involved uh bless
their hearts but they're not always
reliable or honest right i mean have you
found that the ways that the people in
your social simulations responded are
more or less accurate or
have they been
nicer in the simulations than they are
in the real world etc well that's a good
question no i mean i don't think people
are
i don't think people are very nice i
mean i try to focus
people's people on i guess like their
values their needs um
things that
things that it is like relatively easy
to make accurate predictions about it's
like one of the examples that i use
is um
you know if i were to ask you to imagine
um that for whatever reason
you're on an airplane
and and they will allow you to parachute
out if you would like for fun it's a
safe like you know
you could you predict do you think a
year from now if you are likely to say
no thank you i'll wait till the plane
lands or you personally would jump out
like what do you think can you could you
predict that and if so what would you
are you jumping or are you staying until
you land i mean i guess that would
depend on why i got in the plate in the
first place so i'm trying to get
somewhere i'm just gonna let the plane
land if i'm just thrill seeking then i
might jump out okay um so but you you
have a pretty good sense right i could
tell you for sure i don't care what the
scenario is unless it comes with like a
hundred million dollar check i'm gonna
stay on the plane until it lands i do
not wanna i feel like that would
traumatize me for the rest of my life
i'd have flashbacks i don't wanna do it
um some people actually pay money for
the privilege of jumping out of planes
right right right
um
so it's like
i i guess i want to say like
what we have seen now that we've
actually had the chance to live through
crises that are similar to the ones we
were asking people about i mean in
general people in general did what our
players
said they would do um i've tried to do
research i've i've you know interviewed
in-depth interviews 150 players
in 2021 to find out like did you do in
2020 what you imagined doing um and i
would say that in general while people
may change their behavior and especially
for having imagined it what we saw with
world without oil is that just having
imagined adapting to an oil crisis
and and people imagine themselves doing
all these like cool sustainable creative
things
i think that did prime them to actually
do it when
when we a year later the
gas so this was in 2007 in 2008 you may
recall we did have a bit of an oil
crisis and
people players reported doing things
that they had imagined doing now i think
it may have been just a priming effect
like once you've vividly imagined it and
you see yourself as someone likely to
take an action it increases the
likelihood
so it's not that they were necessarily
correct in predicting what they would do
but having predicted it made them more
likely to do it so on that hand i think
it is there's an interesting connection
but but moreover
just
general predictions
seem to map onto
society if you have enough people
participating i wouldn't try this with
10 or 20 people but you know when you
have a thousand or 10 000 or 20 000 you
start to i think have a diversity of
participants where you'll get a more
statistically significant like
correlation to what might play out in
real society well i definitely want to
ask more about the priming thing but but
first since you've been mentioning the
simulation or simulations that you did
about a global pandemic i'm not saying
it's your fault that we actually got a
global pandemic but you were thinking
about it 10 years earlier yeah
and you said that in
large measure
what you saw in the simulation played
out in reality so i mean let's just dig
into a little bit more to what extent
that was true are there things that
truly surprised you when the actual
pandemic hit uh whether it's sort of
misinformation or political polarization
or vaccine denial uh did you did you
anticipate all of these things or were
there some things that we've learned a
lesson because you just missed those
important aspects
yeah i mean two of the things that we
very accurately anticipated
was the the
the threat of misinformation right we
spent a lot of time talking about the
infoedemyology crisis that we might be
anticipating asking participants what
would you do to try to get accurate
information how would you tell what was
you know real and what was
misinformation or just a conspiracy
theory how would you try to help friends
and family who are getting bad
information so we did spend a lot of
time talking about that and i think you
know
were correct in seeing um how
problematic and difficult that would be
for people to
to navigate
what we did not anticipate you know was
essentially
i guess like
governments giving up or
people in power acting in a kind of bad
faith way to downplay the severity or um
i definitely think
that was
i can't recall that coming up at all
this is sort of the idea that some
people would just say whatever that was
not
um something we predicted and it it
wasn't really anything that our players
you know predicted we didn't see a big
i don't i don't recall that coming up at
all that like well some people are just
gonna go about their everyday lives um
people accepted
the
like the crisis aspect and went with
that um
it's it definitely
gave me some food for thought for future
scenarios so um
i was really uh lucky i finally got to
attend a conference that i've always
been wanting to attend um this past year
called the planetary defense conference
i don't know if you know about this it's
based scientists and political leaders
come together to
talk about and share science and
actually run simulations
of
what might happen if an asteroid were
heading towards the earth near earth
objects that pose a threat to human life
and
what's really great is
seeing them start to factor even just
from having lived through this pandemic
things like
what if we forecast an asteroid is
coming but people downplay nobody wants
to evacuate because the government's
saying you know could a government
leader say never this is stupid don't
worry about it um would there be
conspiracy theories
if people
learn about
this area of science and you can
actually go online and see current
forecasts now all the objects are
tracking what the percentage it might
hit what the severity of it might be
what if people start to misuse this to
so panic or to create
um social division they're starting to
look at what we live through these
things that i didn't predict and i don't
know anybody
predicted
this sort of
global shrug
that happened in so many places um
they're they're starting to factor that
in and had sessions on how they would
deal with um you know uh
misinformation and public trust and in
this area of science and so
so yeah we do no matter how
creative
imaginative amazing our simulations and
thought experiments are let's assume
we'll we'll still be surprised by things
but then we can factor that into
our next efforts or our next scenarios
well and having done that and now having
been in a pandemic for a while uh do you
have insight you think about what our
actual future post pandemic is going to
be like uh are we returning to normal
will we always be wearing masks is it a
different world do you think
um
well um
you know
one of our research methods is we look
for signals of change so you know
evidence that change is happening some
shift has occurred or it's just some new
behaviors that are taking place and they
might become more common over time one
of the big signals of change that i'm
really latching on to from from this
sort of heading into a it's not post
pandemic yet i don't but i don't know
what it is um it's like it's the normal
pandemic moment where the pandemic has
been normalized what what's coming out
of it there were two major studies that
found that despite all of the
misinformation conspiracy theories
resistance to math squaring
at the global scale
public trust in science and scientists
has increased
as a direct result of
seeing
the vaccines developed their efficacy
the efficacy of certain recommended
interventions like mask wearing so
despite all the divisiveness and the
emergence of people really resistant
more people trust science more now than
before and
public understanding of the scientific
method and how science works to produce
insight and and recommend actions and
interventions has increased
globally so people trust science and
story and understand such more even if
it doesn't feel like it because of all
the fighting going on on social media
yeah um and to me you know i like to
think one of the long term i think i
think i think i think
is
at some level many people will
trust science more
and the scientific community is is
really
on top of this issue now like realizing
how do we build trust
in science how do we communicate more
effectively how do we make science not
a politically divisive issue because as
we face you know
climate change and and all the things
we're going to be dealing with um in the
future we do need to build and repair
trust in science so i think that to me
that's like
when i'm looking ahead i'm really
looking at that and
how we're going to pour energy into that
and creativity into that uh and i mean
hopefully we're off to a good start
because most people who live through
this are like wow
that worked awesome let's do more let's
do more science yes science is is
helpful it's on our side here um and
good because this is moving us i don't
want to let go of that priming issue
that you mentioned in other words the
idea that once someone has gone through
the simulation
and uh
imagined
what it would be like they are better
prepared for what actually happens and
so this gets us into a lot of the
emphasis of your book which is
even if i'm not involved in the
simulation how do i prep my brain
for things that are going to happen in
the future because it's very hard to do
we're in ruts right we we have a view of
the world today and absent anything else
it's probably going to be like that
tomorrow but of course it won't
predicting how it won't is the hard part
hmm yeah well i mean it's interesting
you say that like if i don't participate
in these simulations because i do think
i mean the one of the things i'm trying
to do in the book is build this general
skill so people can find their own
signals of change and create their own
scenarios um and run their own mental
simulations where they just imagine in
their own mind or they can do social
simulations with other people i mean i
do think at some point you have to pick
up these habits and practice them for it
to work and the smallest habit like the
easiest habit is just collecting signals
of change so making it a habit you know
i say like pick fridays so future
fridays
once a week just do a google news search
for
something that you're interested in like
future of food or future of democracy
see if you can find a news story about a
new policy idea a new scientific
breakthrough a new technology that's
being developed a business model a
social movement try to find evidence of
some form of change that is now starting
to happen and then you're still planning
that in your mind because our failure of
imagination like the reason why we can't
anticipate
these surprising futures is that
if we don't plant
you know
vivid details of what the future might
be like into our minds and our it has
nothing to draw on right like
imagination it needs to reach into that
hippocampus for some facts like some
evidence some clues
we can't just
conjure up realistic possibilities
unless we are looking around the world
and collecting these signals so that's
like the sort of the
the most rudimentary like imagination
habit i want people to develop is
and it works better when you do it with
other people so you can like make a
commitment to text a friend
once a week you're going to have
you know that i'm sending you a signal
and you're gonna have to send me a
signal you do coffee meetups or like
line brown bag lunches at work um you
try to make it social so
because i i think all of this works
better as a community practice just like
games you're more likely to play a game
if somebody else is playing it and
waiting for you to show up
um so yeah collect these and just plant
them in your mind because then what your
brain will do
is when it goes into default mode and
it's just like you're not paying
attention to what's around you you're
just imagining you're like sort of
daydreaming it will draw on these
signals of change that you've planted
there that's waiting in your hippocampus
to be recombined in novel ways so that
you're you're now thinking about well um
you know this is like
this is the first time um i've i've seen
uh
so many people with drones like when i
was i went to this like protest and
everybody had drones and they were using
the drones to document so like now when
i'm just daydreaming i'm gonna put
drones in my daydream and try to imagine
like
what are what are people using them for
for activism or art or storytelling or
journalism or stalking or spreading good
news or whatever we think like you know
um
we we need to collect these
these details so that our imagination is
not
fantasy right it's grounded in real
changes that are already happening
i was definitely struck in the book by
your emphasis on the idea of mental time
travel because that's something we
talked about in the podcast but
usually in the context of
consciousness cognition self-awareness
you know the difference between human
thinking and other species thinking
the ability to imagine different
hypothetical futures right and and
you're sort of
and there is even though we can all do
it
imagine different hypothetical futures
we still
tend to react a little bit to the moment
like when the pandemic hits we're not
instantly thinking oh i will use the
next six months to do my pet project
right we're thinking like i gotta go buy
toilet paper
and this is kind of what you're
suggesting is that it's not just a
phenomenon but a habit of mind that we
should cultivate
well first of all i mean the the future
can be a wonderful place like we've
talked a lot about risks and threats but
going
on these mental time trips far into the
future um one of the interesting things
it does is if you're just trying to
imagine what you might be doing 10 years
in the future so i give people this very
practical exercise i say i want you to
like open your digital calendar so if
you use google calendar or apple
calendar or whatever
tab forward to 10 years in the future
which if you didn't know you can
schedule events 10 years from now you
can actually go 100 years from now i
mean they're very these calendars are
very future
future ready um so go 10 years into the
future and put something on your
calendar for 10 years from today that
you would be
excited about and ideally something you
can't do today and you know if you're
feeling really gameful like invite
someone else like send it send the
calendar invite to your best friend or
to your partner or you know to like kind
of bring someone into your imagination
and what we see is that when people
imagine what they could do 10 years from
now they tend to imagine things that are
different
in a couple of key ways one is we tend
to
we tend to think about
maximal situations so best possible
things biggest goals
most exciting most meaningful um when we
imagine what we might do today or
tomorrow or next week or even next year
we tend to think more minimally we're
more focused on what is
realistic what is what is feasible what
can i definitely accomplish when we tend
to think on further timelines our brain
just sort of experiences this creative
freedom and a sense of hope like you
know yeah 10 years that's a lot of time
to get ready or things to change and
there's nothing i mean go to your
calendar do you have anything on your
calendar for 10 years from today no it's
a blank slate right you have no to-do
list for you know march 31st 2032 you
can do whatever you want so there's this
freedom of imagination and so you know
this is this this practice of mental
time travel it's definitely not just
about preparing for risk or you know
getting ready for disruption it can also
be about getting in touch with uh our
our sense of hope and purpose and and
then we can allow ourselves to imagine
well what would it take
for this calendar event ten years from
now to actually happen but we've got a
lot of time there's no rush you know i
would say like
instead of making a new year's
resolution we could make we could make a
10-year resolution um so that we haven't
failed you know by the first week or the
the end of the first month we're giving
ourselves the luxury of a decade to
change or to achieve um so that's one
thing and then
um
another thing that we see is is that
when we imagine 10 years out we tend to
give more emphasis to our our deepest
values or priorities so the things that
drive us the things that make us
feel like this is my purpose in life
whether it's it's being a good parent or
learning something new every day or
creating art that inspires others or you
know whatever whatever we feel is like
true to our sense of purpose that stuff
comes up
right at the fore when we're imagining
whether it is a crisis scenario what do
you do in this pandemic like musicians
talk about writing protest songs against
the government for not funding the you
know the long care
you know treatment for this disease or
whatever
people put their deepest values and
strengths in service of the future in a
way that we don't always make time for
or prioritize
in the in the rush of the present um
especially if we feel over scheduled or
we feel like time poor we're not in
control of our schedule we're not
control over time we don't have enough
time to do what matters so
so yeah there's a this is like mental
health aspect self-care aspect um
that is is also a part of mental time
travel and so it makes it makes it kind
of like the future is a is an inspiring
place it doesn't have to just be like a
scary place um we can we can inspire
ourselves too i guess the closest thing
i've ever done to that is uh several
years ago i got a payment for you know a
book royalty check and my wife jennifer
and i invested it in
very very nice bottles of wine that we
would save for our 10th 15th and 20th
wedding anniversaries right oh amazing
it totally works like you're literally
waiting for that year to come up so just
so you can like go out and uh go to a
nice restaurant and drink your wine and
what i mean what a beautiful and poetic
act of commitment to each other and it's
saying i mean of course i imagine
being with you in 20 years do you want
to hear a funny story that was in a
version of the book that i wound up
cutting because i you know i i i get
excited i write i write twice as much as
needs to go in the book and then okay
so um i was interviewing people who had
played these games to find out did it
impact your
real world behavior this year during the
pandemic and somebody said oh my god the
best story for you it's like playing
these games it totally changed my life
real world action here it is
so she had played a series of
forecasting games called first five
minutes of the future where you get
these really like lightning round
scenarios and then you journal for five
minutes as if you were in this future
just what you're doing in the first five
minutes so the scenario might be
you get a text message it's like the
emergency alert system saying that
there's a government mandated internet
shutdown the whole internet shutting
down for two weeks for cyber security
threat
what do you do in the first five minutes
and it's going out in an hour so see you
later internet two weeks what do you do
in the first five minutes of getting
this text and so you just journal how do
you feel who are you gonna talk to like
what are you worried about
um so she did like five of these uh over
the course of a week
and then she said at the end of it the
action she decided to take was um filed
for divorce and i was like what
wait what how did that happen and she
said and i was like oh my god this is so
profound she said every journal entry
when i was writing what i was going to
do who i wanted to talk to like what i
was planning how i react she said my
husband wasn't in a single one of these
these moments that i was imagining i
wasn't talking to him about it i wasn't
asking him like what he he just wasn't
there and it sort of drove home for her
you know that they've been growing apart
that they've been refusing to deal with
it anyway you know fast forward she
played these games she filed for divorce
they're separated she's really happy
she's living of what she feels is a
better life but she wasn't able to
acknowledge
what needed to be done
until she really sat with those features
and realized that like when she really
has permission to think about her future
she
she didn't put him in it um and so you
know it kind of gets back to that idea
of like when we go 10 years out
either like you you're seeing the people
you care about who you wanna you
prioritize and you're you're you have
this place for them um or maybe we we
see we we imagine things that like if we
don't change we do we want to be stuck
10 years from now in in the position
that we're in now so i just like the
future is a gift to allow us to really
challenge our assumptions about you know
what should we spend our time on now or
or who is important to us what um what
what can we do
today
just by imagining the future we might
change our perspective on that well you
know life is hard enough from moment to
moment that people can i know i am
certainly in my
science career i know for a fact that i
have spent way too much time thinking
about what i got to do in the next few
months or a couple years and not enough
time about what i need to do 20 years
down the line so it's a very uh
interesting exercise to do and one of
the things that came clear from the book
is the usefulness of the specificity of
imagining the future it's just it's not
just like oh i imagine that i'll be
happy that i'll imagine i'm driving a
blue car
you know something that really anchors
you in that particular specificity of
that future scenario yeah so i always
teach people these specificity induction
techniques so i find that writing
journal entries is a really good way to
make sure that you're vividly imagining
the future almost as if it were a memory
that had already happened right that you
could recall and write in a journal and
there's actually a scoring method where
after you write for five minutes you
count out
you count up the number of details so
visual details did you mention a color a
blue truck okay plus one that's a one
detail um were you describing what you
were wearing or a pain that was in your
body or what the weather was like or
what song is playing on the radio you
know um who's with you what words are
coming out of their mouth the more vivid
specific detail that you bring to
imagination
the more um
the more that this imagination or memory
of the future can change how you feel
and act today so for example if you're
trying to overcome normalcy bias so that
if
you know the next pandemic maybe it's a
tick-borne pandemic instead of a viral
contagious disease it's spread from
ticks if you have vividly imagined
yourself pulling your socks up over your
jeans because that's the new fashion
because everybody's afraid of getting
this you know these tick bites and
you're so as you're getting dressed in
the morning you're imagining well what
if i were in the scenario
and you can the more of these details
you have the more
the more your brain treats these
hypothetical possibilities as worth
taking seriously um and you you pre-feel
them with a stronger emotional intensity
which can essentially it makes all of
these topics more salient to you in the
future so let's say
you know the next time there's like a
weird news story or people are talking
on social media you're going to pick up
those clues faster because your brain
says this is a topic that matters to me
you've locked it in you're going to get
that dopamine hit from the next headline
that you see
whereas people who haven't vividly
imagined it their brain doesn't have a
connection to this topic they don't so
anyway yes for all kinds of reasons
more specificity is better and you can
count up the number of details and you
can try to work on
being somebody who has more details or
you can rewrite your journal entry if
you only had five details okay i'll say
you've got another five minutes now i
want to see 15 details in there
and it doesn't really matter what the
details are right if you're imagining a
blue truck or a red chuck it doesn't
matter but it matters to your brain
in that
it makes this future more imaginable
literally more imaginable when you try
to think about it it's going to bring
this this movie into your mind or this
3d environment into your mind so you can
really
revisit it and think about it and allow
it to motivate you or inform your
actions
so you've mentioned the importance of
realizing that we can imagine futures
that are not just
disaster scenarios and terrible things
happening but also good things happening
and there's a balance to be struck there
uh for anyone who's listening to the
mindscape podcast 200 years in the
future not only are we right now
in the recovery period of a pandemic but
we're in month two of uh the invasion of
the ukraine by russia right and which
has the potential
in some hypothetical future scenarios to
grow into a superpower clash and a
nuclear war
uh i mentioned this on twitter recently
i was i was accused of peddling disaster
porn rather than being realistic but
so i mean rather than saying my own
opinion let me ask you how do you
balance the worst possible things
happening from the best is it is it sort
of cheap and easy to air too much on one
side or the other or is there a happy
meeting i love this question i'm gonna
try to answer it very slowly and
methodically because it's very important
okay
so
what what i encourage people to do and
what we practice at the institute for
the future is to have an active balance
of what we call positive imagination and
shadow imagination so positive
imagination that's made up of the
futures that we want the world you want
to wake up in where you know economic
inequality has been solved racial
injustice has been solved cars are
banned from cities like whatever
whatever futures excite you that you
would like to wake up in that's your
positive imagination then you've got
your shadow imagination where you are
willing to acknowledge real risks and
threats like nuclear war still a threat
even though we stopped talking about it
as much for a couple decades you know
let's let's actually bring that back up
into our consciousness and and so the
need for new approaches to nuclear
disarmament i mean we need to get out of
this weird stalemate and
figure out you know people in nuclear
security would argue they've got to be
new new methods for disarmament because
this is taking too long and it's not
it's not having any lasting or
transformative impact so you're you've
got the shadow imagination you've got
the positive imagination and what
what becomes important is that you can
assess new situations developing
situations using what's in your positive
imagination and in your shadow
imagination so let's say there's some
new technology you're excited about
right the new unfolding situation is a
neurostimulation technology this is
something i'm actually very interested
and excited about um there there
that there is uh the possibility for
neural implants to essentially cure
intractable depression um and this is
exciting okay i can i can use it to fuel
my hope for the future of mental health
care but maybe i can also think about
these other things in my shadow
imagination like economic inequality who
will have access to it think about the
rise of authoritarian you know politics
will will somebody come up with a misuse
for this technology how are we going to
regulate it you know so
so if you're excited about a future
let your shadow imagination inform it
likewise with the war that we're living
through now
we want to balance
you know the the
the justified dread and anxiety and
despair we have over this suffering
can we look for
ways that the positive
futures we've imagined
can we pull those positive imagination
as possible into the present somehow and
create a connection so one thing that is
always on my mind my one of my top
futures is the future of migration and
particularly around climate change and
i'm worried that we might
force people to stay trapped behind
geopolitical boundaries and live in
parts of the world that are now no
longer conducive to human life because
of extreme heat or extreme drought i'm
worried that we're not going to
transform our border policies or
migration policies fast enough to
prevent mass suffering i'm very
interested in climate migration and new
approaches to that um so i've been
trying to encourage people to imagine
what change we might experience how we
might become more welcoming to refugees
how we might change the conversation so
migrants aren't a threat
but that it's it's something that we can
have a more positive narrative around so
at
you know this one spark of hope for what
i'm seeing is the unprecedented response
to refugees leaving ukraine and how
they're being welcomed and the details
the specificity of it people are meeting
them at the border they are they are
bringing things they are opening their
homes they are they're trying to
um
to show up for this crisis
now there's a level of racism involved
you know poland wants to accept these
refugees because they're white and
they're christian
but
so at the same time they're going to
have a lived experience of being heroic
in this way the world is going to
witness this people like my kids might
grow up
having this narrative in their mind this
is what we do we welcome people in
crisis we open our homes we open our
communities
this is great this is this is what we do
now
so i try now i'm trying to bring that
future i want
a future where we can welcome each other
when we're in crisis across borders i'm
trying to bring that and connect it with
what's happening now and is there
anything i can do
to
to help this be a tipping point for the
the culture of
of migration so that coming out of this
again going 10 years in the future where
hopefully
the war is over and we have not
sustained any nuclear damage i mean
hopefully we're going to go 10 years out
how are we using this experience 10
years from now to
to develop a more humane approach to
human movement or whatever it might be
so it's this dance that we do when we
think about things that seem positive
let's make sure we're bringing in the
awareness of risks or injustice or
inequality whatever and then if we're
thinking about if we're living through
you know crisis and disruption and
suffering
how do we find a place for the future we
want still and try to try to create
those connections i don't know if you
saw just the other day a new poll came
out uh that seemed to indicate that
for the first time in decades a majority
of americans would like to see more
immigration than we currently have
rather than less immigration than we
currently have
great i love it you know also i saw a
headline that for the first time we had
more death than human than births um in
the united states which is another
reason to consider more migration right
like aging populations we're not going
to be able to sustain
life as we know it um without
without young people so there i mean
these and that's the thing when you
start to
like pay attention to signals of change
you start to see like well there are
lots of
drivers of change that might be pushing
you know in the same direction and it
helps you think like yeah we're really
on the precipice of a new way of
thinking about migration like i want to
get ready for that um yeah well and it's
very related to another thing that you
mentioned in the book um
i interviewed paul bloom on the podcast
he had this wonderful book against
empathy and i was completely against
against empathy so we had a
fun disagreement uh because his argument
is you know we should be rational rather
than empathetic empathy is something
that we are
more likely to have for people who are
like ourselves and that biases us and in
your book you very nicely
contrast that kind of empathy which is
easy empathy with hard empathy the
empathy that we have to work to get for
people who are unlike ourselves and and
that plays a role in
maybe being a good person but also just
in accurately thinking about the future
yeah exactly um and it's one of the
reasons why i like
running social simulations rather than
just giving people future scenarios to
sort of sit in their own mind
try to bring communities and groups
together so that
we can see how other people react to a
scenario and um i i was doing this for a
while around universal basic income
which like people have these sort of
abstract opinions while it's not right
to pay people for nothing or if we give
people ubi they'll just stay home and
play video games or it'll it'll you know
create a sort of laziness and people
have like these
i'm in favor of universal basic income
so i'm saying those arguments you know
and then a tone of voice that probably
conveys that i don't i don't find them
to be persuasive um but
so you know
let's develop some hard empathy for
people whose lives might be transformed
by universal basic income you know i can
hear it's like i might say to someone i
hear you say you don't need universal
basic income you prefer to earn your
income through work that that is
meaningful to you and purposeful to you
and you have you have a job that allows
you to do that great
now let's talk about let's let's let's
have some other people
share what they would do if they had
this money oh like this person says that
i would quit my second job so that i
could spend more time with my kids if i
had this income or
you know um
i i would like to be more involved in
volunteering in my community and maybe i
could work less and volunteer more i
could instead of hiring somebody to take
care of my parents maybe i could be more
involved in that
what what people say you know
when you can actually hear
real people respond to hypothetical
future scenarios it takes us out of this
i don't know this sort of abstract
opinions or politically divisive like
feelings
and we can just
understand that there are reasons why
some people might want a particular
future or likewise
why people might not want a particular
future you know you might have all these
people excited about a new technology or
a new policy that they think is going to
lift humanity and then you might talk to
people who
historically have been marginalized or
harmed by new technologies and they
would say well here's you know let's
think about this a little bit more
because i i would be worried about this
it doesn't mean that their fears are
founded necessarily but it's good to
know that there's going to be resistance
or you know that we need to heal this
pre-existing guy trauma in order to get
people to accept this new possibility um
so hard empathy we can develop it by
just
actually seeing the future from other
people's points of view and we to do
that we can play these games together we
can have you know we started a scenario
club at the institute for the future we
have uh
850 members now who come together once a
month to just it's like a book club meet
up except instead of talking about a
book we talk about a future scenario and
what we would feel and we vote on
whether we're excited about it or we're
worried about it and um it's it's just
this this is a good skill also to
develop this ability to get outside our
own
reactions and intuitions and and
actually hear from other people
this is how it would impact me or how i
would feel about it well it also sounds
like it's crucially important for the
idea of democracy which is uh under
threat in various different ways but you
know everyone thinks that the people who
disagree with them are the real threat
to democracy and i i
increasingly worry that no one is
willing to accept or anyway it's
becoming less common to accept that
democracy is about living with people
who disagree with you right i mean
that's not going to go away that that's
what we have to learn to do if the
system is going to work um i love that i
mean what an interesting like
rebrand for democracy i mean we we do at
the institute for the future spend a lot
of time thinking about the future of
democracy
and um and how to preserve it and and
revitalize it and that's that's very
interesting
idea like
that we lean into that instead of
because i do think you're right like a
lot of people approach democracy as
uh
as a struggle to convince other people
essentially that you're right and
they're wrong right um so how do how do
we rebrand it and and think about um
coexisting
and you know maximizing the non-zero
outcomes and like it i like it i like it
you're right that we don't think about
it that way
that could be really helpful i'll i'll
try to come up with a scenario for
scenario club um that that thinks about
democracy the new it's like the new way
that we talk about it what will it be
okay i'm on it good glad to do that and
and you know maybe it's useful to wind
up here with just some big picture
speculation because you've given us a
lot to think about in terms of how to
visualize the future and how to
get our own brains out of the ruts that
we're in so let me just ask you know and
and we always let our hair down near the
end of the podcast uh what have we
learned you know what have you what do
you think are
the things that the person on the street
should expect about the future from
these uh simulations that you've done
positively or negatively what are you
optimistic about what are the big
worries that you uh have that people
aren't worried enough about i mean i
think big picture what i'm telling
everyone is we need to be more flexible
we need to
be more
willing to change plans or change
practices whether it's you know i live
in california where now we have a
wildfire season and
certain things aren't safe now during
certain times of the year like being
outside um we're gonna have to get
flexible about for example the school
year calendar
people don't want to be
in california during wildfire season but
it starts the same time the school year
starts are we going to start to have
more flexibility around this
this
practically ancient tradition it's not
ancient it goes back to like you know
when
industrial schooling began um but this
is flexibility in our calendars and our
practices you know we until we rebuild
our electrical grid i mean there may be
less stability and
power supply are you
more flexible and ready to like you know
just
go with this
go with the flow if you don't have
energy do you have what you need like i
don't mean this in like a scary
apocalyptic way i think i think it's
just going to be
how we maintain
our well-being
is is just to accept that things can
change on short notice um or permanently
and uh
and and heading into the future with
that
that
we don't we don't want to grasp to
expectations just just be ready things
you may you may need to you may need to
be behave differently or schedule
differently or let go of a plan that you
made and make a new plan um and then you
know i i said it before but i think i
think movement around the planet is
going to is
and it excites me because you know if if
people can move a little more freely on
the planet they can go someplace where
they can contribute to society more they
can they can work they can create they
can care for for people i mean
i think if we're willing to
rethink our assumptions about
about human human rights to move freely
and to seek out opportunity or safety i
think if we lean into that we could
design higher density cities than we've
ever lived in before and that could be
amazing for
a new renaissance of what is it like to
live
with so many people bouncing ideas and
culture and
the social experience of that uh so i
mean i'm saying like pay attention to
what's going on around that and lean
into that and be ready for that um not
in a scary way but in a you know could
we establish a new human right to move
freely could we live in higher density
in a way that is incredibly green and
art flourishes and you know ideas
flourish let's let's let's be ready for
a decade or two of transformation there
uh so this is a perfect place to end the
podcast i always like to end on an
optimistic note but nevertheless i still
have one more question which is as a
fellow californian what does your
earthquake kit look like
i mean what we've got lots of water i
mean our main thing we've got
flashlights and water that's our amine
and
[Music]
yeah the earthquake the earthquake one
is uh
yeah it's a tough one it's it's
interesting uh
why water is water is the big one
water's the big one it's hard because
you can you can survive without food for
a while um but if you need to get your
own water um that's going to be so we
have a lot of we have a lot of water
since you said ending on an optimistic
note
can i also suggest if folks want to join
our scenario club or actually
we're going to be running two social
simulations at the institute for the
future this year one on climate
migration and one on geoengineering
decision making and unanticipated
consequences
they can join us at urgent optimists
plural because it's a bunch of us dot
org they can they can join the scenario
club because i want people to like i
don't want people to just i want people
to read the book imaginable and i also
want them to join the community of
practice so that um you know this is
collective imagination we're talking
about so i don't want people to just
read the book on their own i want them
to come and now play together with
others at urgent optimists that is very
good that is an excellent optimistic
place to and i will put a link to it in
the show notes awesome and everyone can
visit so jane mcgonagall thanks so much
for being the mindscape podcast
[Music]
you